Sascha filipenko der 38-Jährige
belarussische Autor ist ein bekannter
Kritiker des Lukaschenko
regims 2020 musste er das Land verlassen
lebt mit seiner Familie mittlerweile im
Schweizer Exil doch auch dort sind
regimkritiker polizeilichem Terror
ausgesetzt oft vermittelt über
Angehörige die im Land verblieben sind
so drangen im November Behörden in die
Wohnung von filipenkos Vater ein
verhafteten ihn 15 Tage wurde er in
Gewahrsam genommen unter elektroshoocks
wurde er gezwungen sich von seinem Sohn
zu
distanzieren auf Facebook schrieb
philipenko die Polizei habe zu seiner
Mutter gesagt dafür könnt ihr euch bei
eurem Sohn
bedanken seit den massiven Protesten
gegen die offensichtlich gefälschten
Präsidentenwahlen 2020 ließ das Regime
tausende Kritiker innen verhaften und
misshandeln auch in seinen Geschichten
beschreibt filipenko wie es ist wenn man
von einem übermächtigen Apparat verfolgt
wird vieles was er in seinen Büchern
festhält hat er selbst erlebt es geht um
Einschüchterung und Zermürbung wenn man
es mit Oligarchen aufnimmt wie
Lukaschenko und Putin für filipenko
haben beide Diktatoren dieselbe Methodik
die brutale Niederschlagung von allem
was sich ihrer Macht in den Weg
stellt und jetzt spreche ich mit dem
Schriftsteller Sascha filipenko schönen
Abend nach
Basel gut ab ja ich bin in Bas wie geht
es ihrem Vater heute wie hat er die Haft
überstanden jetzt
freekommen er ist natürlich unter Stress
aber ich glaube HT das gut
dur hat vi erzäh davon was mit dem
passiert ist ist
schcklich es wird of gesagt dass
50.000chen in Belus in Haft war und fast
jeder hat
volb was haben sie
ihremля 202
zle für vier Personen werden 20 bis 22
Personen gehalten man kann tagsüber nur
stehen man kann sich nicht hinlegen 24
Stunden am Tag brennt das Licht ich habe
meinen Vater gefragt wie hast du denn
geschlafen er hat mir erzählt die ersten
drei Tage kann man nicht schlafen und
dann gewöhnt sich der Körper daran so
dass man auch bei Licht schlafen kann
einige Wochen lang konnte er nicht nach
draußen so wie die anderen Häftlinge man
hat die Brille weggenommen konnte nichts
lesen das ist nichts anderes als
vololter in dem
Gerichtsurteil war die Rede von einem
Link den ihr Vater geteilt hat hat das
Regime wirklich Angst vor exilmedien wie
zerkalo also diesen Link den er geteilt
hat oder sucht es nur ein Vorwand um
Angehörige von Aktivisten wie ihn zu
drangalieren natürlich ist es nur ein
Vorwand mein havater wurde
verhaftet wurdeier gebracht und als
erstes hat man fragen über mich gestellt
man hat im meine Fotos mitansk mit
alexwi mit dem Präsidenten der Schweiz
gezeigt man hat nur von mir gesprochen
bei diesem Verhör man hat seine
Smartphone
durchgesucht und man hat ganz offen
gesagt wir können ihren Sohn nicht
kriegen aber wir haben sie
gekriegt das heißt der Link auf serkal
war nur ein Vorwand um ih für 15 Tage zu
verhaften viele in Belarus löschen Ihre
Posts und Likes aus ihren timelines die
für sie problematisch sein könnten was
macht das denn mit der kollektiven
Erinnerung oder ist sowas wie kollektive
Erinnerung ein Luxusproblem gerade
ja ja ich glaube man kann das
tatsächlich aus den timelines löschen
aber man kann es nicht aus der
Erinnerung
löschen also das
heißt irgendwine bleibt als gespeicherte
Kopie natürlich kümmert man sich um die
eigene
Sicherheit andererseits wenn sie nichts
auf dem Telefon haben dann ist es auch
sehr verdächtig für die Machthabenden
das heißt man muss eine Balance finden
nicht alles löschen einees lassen damit
die Polizei kein Verdacht HT aber wieer
ma sei kann belarussische Polizei ein
Vorwand finden um sie einzusperren wenn
Sie das möchten und hat sich das seit
dem Start des russischen Krieges in der
Ukraine
verschlimmert seit am Anfang des Krieges
in Ukraine hat man Belarus komplett
vergessen
2020 hat Europa für das belarussische
Volk geschwerbt man hat sehr viel von
uns gesprochen man hat gesagt wir würden
für die Freiheit kämpfen und dann
plötzlich im Jahr
2022 wurden wir zu einem erklärt man hat
vergessen dass es auch Repression in
belaruss gibt und ich glaube das
belarussische Regime fühlt sich jetzt
gut die Repression wird fortgesetzt
jeden Tag werden Leute eingesperrt
verhaftet und so denkt das belarussische
Regime dass man jetzt alles machen kann
denn belaruss ist nicht mehr auf der
europäischen
Tagesordnung in einer Situation wie
dieser hilft oder schadet ihre Prominenz
da der für die sie kämpfen und auch
ihrem Vater wenn er in so eine Situation
gerät wie die in die geraten
ist das ist eine schwierige Frage wir
verstehen natürlich dass mein Vater ein
Geisel in Belarus ist er kann das Land
nicht
verlassen Bürger von Belarus können
jetzt das Land nicht verlassen denn sie
brauchen sie jetzt ein spezielles
Ausreisevisum dazu brauchen sie auch ein
Einreisevisum nach Europa also zwei Visa
ichinlich prominenter Schriftsteller
aber denken Sie daran dass 500.000
Menschen bereits das Land Verl verlassen
haben aber ihre Angehörigen bleiben in
Belarus als Geisel und es werden nicht
nur die Verwandten jetzt eingesperrt
aber auch Freunde und Bekannte deswegen
ist es sehr wichtig weiter darüber zu
reden das ist nicht nur meine Geschichte
das ist nicht nur die Geschichte von
Prominenten Oppositionellen das ist eine
Geschichte von jedem belarussischen
Bürger der jetzt Angst hat
nach Belus zuisen viele Leute können
nicht zur Beerdigung von Vater oder
Mutter kommen denn sie haben Angst
verhaftet zu werden wenn Sie persönlich
nach Belarus zu diesem Anlass Reisen in
ihrem aktuellen Buch beschreiben sie ja
die Absurdität des Alltags in der
Stalinzeit in der Sowjetunion der hält
des Buches begegnet dem abgeklärt
stoisch ist es in der Realität von
Belarus heute möglich sich so eine
Haltung zu bewahren ja
ich glaube diese Frage sollte man an
diejenigen richten die jetzt in belaruss
Leben ich kann diese Haltung nicht
bewahren deswegen bin ich weg ich
verstehe dass ich in der im heutigen
Belarus
nicht Haft sein könnte also ich könnte
nicht frei sein wir sehen dass sehr
wenig sich geändert hat einige Minister
einige generale in
Belarus V vom
NKWD bei einer staatlichen Parade
getragen man kann es damit vergleichen
also so ein analog könnte irgin
Staatsminister Deutschlands die SS
Uniform anziehen aber das passiert und
das heißt sie haben diese Stafel von der
stalenzeit übernommen und die
Grausamkeiten von heute passieren jetzt
weil es kein überdenken kein
Aufarbeitung von den Geschehnissen der
stalenzeit gegeben hat Herr philopenko
ich wünsche Ihnen und Ihrer Familie
alles Gute und ihnen Aufmerksamkeit für
ihren Kampf
danke vielen
Dank